hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast pancreatic cancer
challenges and solutions presented by
dr. Lynne matura Sheehan chief science
officer at the Pancreatic Cancer Action
Network I'm Susie Malthus of lab routes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
events
well divided to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
type that question into the box and it
that appears on the screen and we'll
answer as many as we can
toward the end of the presentation also
notice that you'll be viewing this
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem good news this presentation is
educational and offers educational
continuing credits click on the button
at the bottom left hand corner to follow
in a pro and obtain your credits please
join me now in welcoming our presenter
dr. Lynne mitrice Ian I will now turn
the presentation over to her welcome dr.
my Tracy van
hello thank you Susie so I'll be talking
today about pancreatic cancer the
challenges and solutions of this deadly
disease let's talk first about the
challenges so pancreatic cancer is the
twelfth most common cancer so it is not
when we hear a lot about it is about 3.2
percent of all the new cancer cases and
we hear mostly about the big four breast
cancer prostate lung and colorectal
cancer so it's not a cancer that's
particularly on our horizon at most
times however pancreatic cancer is
projected to be the second major cancer
killer around the year 2020 it is the
third major killed killer right now it's
surpassed breast cancer this year in the
number of cancer deaths in the United
States and it's on track to surpass
colorectal cancer around the year 2020
to become second only to lung cancer as
a major cancer killer so it's one that
we need to spend more attention to in
order to pay more attention to as we go
forward so primarily I'm talking about
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma or PPAC
it represents ninety-five percent of all
the pancreatic cancer histologies in
addition there is neuro endocrine
pancreatic cancer and several other
histological types but we'll focus
particularly on P dag it has a five-year
survival rate in the single digits and
so is considered one of the
deadliest or a Woodhouse Oh Trent cancer
and that's a definition that's defined
legislatively as cancers with the
five-year relative survival rate of less
than fifty percent so this represents of
the major cancers the deadliest within
that category
the reason is for one reason it's
diagnosed late only about 15% of
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma cases
are acceptable in go to surgery and it's
characterized by 95 percent of these
cases have as their driver mutations in
the oncogene k wrasse it has it's also
distinctive and that has a very robust
stroma and you can see from the H&E on
this slide that there are islands of
pancreatic cancer cells within a sea of
the pink stroma or the desmo plastic
response to those cancer cells this
causes an elevated pressure within the
tumor it prevents it collapses blood
vessels and prevents adequate nutrition
and oxygen to reach those cancer cells
so they become very hypoxic and it
prevents chemo therapies from reaching
those cells so it's a distinctive
characteristic of pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma and in addition pede acts
are amia logically cold so that's very
we've had a difficult time in finding
immuno therapies that are effective
against this cancer type so this
presents great challenges for pancreatic
cancer
so at the Pancreatic Cancer Action
Network we set a goal in 2011 to double
survival by 2020 and started a number of
initiatives with this goal in mind so
our organization is really focused on on
this all of our activities
are really centered around reaching this
goal and in another couple years we'll
need to set a new goal as we use this as
the foundation to make really
substantial advances against this cancer
time so let's talk about the solutions
some of the solutions that we've come up
with to attack this cancer so our plan
is for one thing we realize that there's
not that research is essential more
research in this field we need to
increase an influence both government
and private funding for research and
pancreatic cancer we need to increase
the clinical trial enrollment rate so
clinical research we need to get more
patients on to trial so we can learn
faster we need to promote running smart
clinical trials so the clinical trials
that are ongoing we need to be very
focused on increasing survival for this
cancer we need to identify the best
practice and disseminate them across the
country there's a lot of variability in
the treatment of pancreatic cancer there
are community oncologists who only see a
couple pancreatic cancer patients a year
and don't necessarily do well and so
there are spent also Centers of
Excellence that really focus on this
disease and so we need to learn from
those Centers of Excellence and
disseminate that information to all
oncologists that treat pancreatic cancer
and we need to heighten public awareness
and raise more money for this disease
and so that creates a real sense of
urgency as we march towards our 2020
goal to accomplish these goals so first
in increasing influencing government and
private funding for research the
National Cancer Institute provides a
little over 80% of the pancreatic cancer
funding within the United States and so
our advocacy efforts as a patient
advocacy group have helped to influence
the funding levels for pancreatic cancer
within the National
Cancer Institute we've seen a dramatic
increase of five-fold increase in NCI
funding devoted to pancreatic cancer
since the inception of the beginning of
the pancreatic cancer action network in
1999 and some dramatic increases in
recent years in part this is due to
continual advocacy I'm going to the hill
and making sure our elected
representatives are aware of the role of
National Cancer Institute and the
National Institutes of Health play in
funding research for this disease and
it's also as a result of a specific bill
called the recalcitrant Cancer Research
Act this is a bill that was introduced
several times it became it passed
Congress in 2012 and was enacted into
law by President Obama in January of
2013 it was an enormous advocacy effort
that resulted in the passage of this
bill and what the bill did was ask the
NCI
to develop a scientific framework for
pancreatic cancer
it had no appropriations but it asked
for a strategic plan for the NCI to
devote efforts towards pancreatic cancer
the result was a NE a group that came
together a group of scientists that
identified four priority areas for
pancreatic cancer research and the NCI
has been very responsive to those
priority areas they have set up
consortiums and different initiatives to
address each of these in since that bill
was passed in 2013 there is a effort at
the Frederick National Laboratory to
focus particularly on rasped ribbon
cancers and so since pancreatic cancer
is
95% of pdx are driven by alterations in
the Alpha gene a mass that there's these
efforts to try to drug what's been
considered an undruggable target have
really been catalyzed by this effort
through the National the Frederick
National Laboratory the relationship
between diabetes and pancreatic cancer
has been investigated through a
partnership with the NID UK and the NCI
resulting in the consortium to study
chronic pancreatitis diabetes and
pancreatic cancer early detection of
pancreatic cancer has been funded
through our pancreatic cancer detection
consortium and immunotherapy approaches
to pancreatic cancer it's the most
recent initiative the consortium for
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma Studies
on the - microbiome that has really
focused on understanding the the immune
system in the micro environment of
pancreatic cancer and there's been
committed funding funding that is going
into East each of these initiatives and
content and these initiatives will
continue in the future years to provide
some of the much-needed research in this
cancer in addition the Pancreatic Cancer
Action Network has a competitive peer
reviewed' Grants Program we've invested
over 40 million dollars over since 2000
the program started in 2003 giving
grants to over 58 institutions across
the United States with a very concerted
effort to form a community for progress
to make sure that the pancreatic cancer
investigators know each other that
they're collaborating know that they're
working together to provide the research
on this disease
so in addition we've been working on
increasing the clinical trial enrollment
rate for this cancer type and this
really focuses on our resource that
we've had since 2002 a call center that
we call patient central so I'll place
the one-to-one support for patients and
caregivers that are that are facing
pancreatic cancer so our highly trained
associates on the telephone give
information customized and information
to what that individual is asking at
that particular time giving information
on disease and treatments on clinical
trials on support resources that they
might be interested at every step along
their journey there's an education
packet that's mailed within 24 hours
providing information on the disease
recommendations to go to a high-volume
center for or a second opinion or for
treatment and each person who calls if
they call back again at a later time
will be reconnected me the same
associate so they can pick up where they
left off and continue that conversation
so one of the a very important part of
the services service that's provided by
patient central is our clinical trial
database and this database is kept up to
date on a monthly basis we call it call
around to all clinical trials that are
open and there's approximately 160
clinical trials open for pancreatic
cancer at any one time within the United
States and we get up-to-date information
of the sites but those files are open
whether they are open that we can get
that information to on patients as they
ask in addition this database is
available to patients online through our
clinical trial finder and it's available
to healthcare professionals to do
searches to look at the landscape of
clinical trials throughout the United
States so because we have a relationship
with trial
answers throughout the United States
every three years we do an analysis of
the number of pancreatic ductal annual
carcinoma patients that went on clinical
trials in that particular year our
national average in 2011 was 3.8 percent
of the prevalence of the number of
pancreatic cancer patients in the United
States went on clinical trials in that
year it increased slightly in 2014 to
4.2 percent but we find that patient
central callers those that call us that
get clinical trial information and that
respond to a survey we find twelve
percent of those go on non clinical
trials so helping to buy through the
information that's available through
clinical trial finder and through this
clinical trial database in our nation's
central associates to we find this we
find that the knowledge about clinical
trials helps increase the clinical trial
enrollment rate so patients go on
clinical trials they need to be smart
clinical trials they need to be ones
that will really advance the future so
we as at the Pancreatic Cancer Action
Network we have taken a look at the
pancreatic cancer clinical trials across
the United States and looked in
particular at the phase three clinical
trials that have led to changes in the
standard of care for this disease so we
did an analysis looked at there were 39
phase 3 pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
trials from 1992 to 2015 but of those we
really only resulted in three clinically
meaningful changes in the standard of
care during that time period so that's a
less than 10% success and so why have we
not been so effective in clinical trials
within this disease so it we looked at
some of the reasons and some of them
related to their work days there were
phase two clinical trials that were done
in advance of the phase three clinical
trials for only a percentage of those of
those phase three clinical trials and it
turned out even if those phase 2 trials
didn't always meet their second second
their primary endpoint they still went
on to face three clinical trials and so
we found that trusting meaning of Phase
two endpoint was predictive of the the
outcome of phase three clinical trials
seventy six percent of the time and so
that that would even if the endpoints
were different and so the in essence
looking at the data not being over
optimistic about the results of Phase
two trials would help predict a response
in a phase three trial in addition we
send some bets and benchmarks using this
retrospective data that might be useful
for prospective for future phase three
clinical trials certain benchmarks for
overall survival one-year survival and
progression-free survival in Phase two
trials that might help predict
effectiveness in the endpoint in the
outcome of a phase three trial and so
had we looking back again
retrospectively on the phase three
clinical trials within the pancreatic
cancer space had we set these benchmarks
for the Phase two files before going on
to Phase three there was 11 more than
11,000 patients that could have been
reallocated to for instance more phase 2
trials looking at other treatment
approaches to these to pancreatic cancer
in addition we we think that as we look
back that we've been thinking about
pancreatic cancer as pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma that's one size fits all
that and so there has been known
molecular there's been very little
precision medicine thinking about
molecular indicators molecular drivers
of pancreatic cancer that can result in
changes in the standard of care and
targeted therapies so this has been
successful in other cancers and
certainly the famous chronic myelogenous
leukemia and Mad Men and a number of
other cancer types there are targeted
therapies that for a subset of patients
in the solid tumors there are subsets of
patients that can be matched then with
the targeted therapy and really change
the survival and the standard of care
within those disease types so we looked
at that in pancreatic cancer realized
three years ago three or four years ago
that there was really not a lot of work
that was being done in this field and
that there was a lot of skepticism that
molecular targeting it was going to work
in pancreatic cancer in particularly
because so many of those trainers are
driven by class alterations which was
and still is audible but we decided that
we needed to to ask that question and
find out whether they were molecular
alterations targeted alterations in
pancreatic cancer so we started Miller
tuna program taking advantage of the
patients that call patient central and
the access to to those to those
individuals so though your tumor works
by patients that call patient central if
they meet the eligibility requirements
which are quite broad but that we have
to be able to obtain a biopsy get to
mortician from these patients and we
have to have enough time for the results
to come back before they need to make
their next treatment decision we
partnered with prepare up for their
against the patient consent assist with
obtaining the biopsy then the tissue is
centralized in conveyors laboratories
and then sent out for testing to
commercial testing laboratories at the
moment we're using foundation medicine
for next-generation sequencing and neo
genomics for immunohistochemistry
the results then come back to Perth era
they have consolidated both proteomics
and the next-generation sequencing
results are put into a report that is
then list treatment options for that
patient based not only on the molecular
alterations that they observed but on
the patient's treatment history and
evident and the other information that's
available about the current state of the
pancreatic cancer field now that report
is sent to the treating physician and to
the patient and to a pancreatic cancer
action network we follow up with the
patient that there are follows up with
the patient and the physician and get
outcomes data which is then analyzed a
patient is also encouraged to put
additional information information
imported registry so the know your tumor
program has been going on since June of
2014 they've enrolled only 1300 patients
with over 700 reports that have come
back at this point in time we're
successful 91% of the time in obtaining
biopsies that we can obtain
next-generation sequencing and
immunohistochemistry if and if and
overall they're 99 were successful 99%
at that time if we get sometimes
[Music]
on the treatment space 91 6% successful
kind of off the bat for these patients
35 percent of the patients come from
community physicians and this is again
any incidence where the patient is often
requesting that the physician especially
in community settings performed
molecular testing since it is not
routine in this cancer type and we have
enrolled patients into this program
throughout 48 states what we find is
that the know your tumor program also
helps with clinical trial enrollment so
clinical trials aren't listed as an
option on those reports that come back
and we find you can increase the
clinical trial in the moment that
patients that undergo their training
program to 21% so another way that we
can encourage patients to enroll in
clinical trials we have any total
evidence lots of stories about patients
where we've identified a rare molecular
alteration in a pancreatic cancer and
suggested either a clinical trial or
off-label treatment with a targeted
therapy that has been that is has been
shown to be effective in another cancer
type and I've seen some some really nice
responses in those cases and it was
treated with a drug that's used in you
know Noma often abused eccentric
mutation and responded nicely with with
significant any reductions and is
certainly feeling much better in
addition we do collect outcomes from the
know your tumor patient we have a from
the first 614 reports that we got we
have analyzed that data and have a
manuscript that's currently in
we find that 27% of pancreatic cancer
patients that we that come through this
program have highly actionable
alterations we define them as ones where
there is evidence in other cancer types
that there are responses to a targeted
therapy that's directed to that
alteration alteration another 23% have
alterations that indicate a pathway not
be activated in which there is a
targeted therapy but very little
evidence that that targeted therapy will
be effective and another 50% we really
see no indicated any alterations that
have a targeted therapy that would be
molecularly indicated
so the type of results that we see are
shown here about 15% of patients have
automations in DNA damage repair
pathways for instance in the breast
cancer genes block Alana Crockett - or
other genes within that related to DNA
damage repair there are ones that
indicate and a Keiichi inhibitor may be
effective and a number of other very low
prevalence alterations and things like
that and track the RAF out ross that
fusions or all mutations that indicate
the possibility of a treatment response
to a specifically targeted therapy to
those alterations we also test for
microsatellite instability with these
patients so the outcomes data we have
again started to collect outcomes data
it's still well initial in these pretty
early in terms of getting outcomes from
these patients but we find that 81% of
patients that receive any
nagarjuna report choose treatment
options that are presented in the report
some of these are standard of care
treatments that are the options that are
really available to this these patients
16% have gone on to off-label targeted
therapies as a result of the report and
21% have on clinical trials so if we
look at progression-free survival and
second line and third line treatment for
these patients who have gone on a
targeted therapy that was indicated by
the number two in report we can start to
get some outcome data so if we look at
those individuals with highly actionable
alterations that went on a match there
we have outcome person three survival
outcome results we see a median
conversion three survival of 4.1 months
and when we compare that to those with
no highly actionable alterations they
have a median progression-free survival
of two point eight months so about a 50%
increase in survival related to this
there are some patients that have highly
not actionable alterations that went on
an unmatched therapy and in those cases
the the median progression-free survival
is not statistically different from the
no actionable no highly actionable
alteration but there is a statistical
difference between the highly actionable
alterations would match there and those
highly actionable observations and so
this is encouraging in terms of in those
that one that one size doesn't fit all
in those incidences where we can
identify a molecular targeted therapy
these patients have responded um with
increased survival
so the know your tumor program is
dependent on the clinical trials that
are open in across the United States we
keep track of those clinical trials and
have looked throughout the last couple
years at many trends and changes in the
landscape Pedic clinical trials what we
have observed is an increase in the
clinical trials with targeted therapies
over the past five years between 2011
and 2015 again a marked increase in in
the number of trials with targeted
therapy and in particular those trials
are in the second or our third line
setting so there are individuals who
have who have recurrent disease after
previous treatment metastatic disease
and so we see again an encouraging trend
towards an increase in the recognition
that targeted therapy can be applied to
[Music]
the patients then that go through your
tour program a lot of times meet the
clinical trials we indicate if they are
rare alterations and there are no
clinical trials specifically for
pancreatic cancer for those alterations
we take advantage of national efforts by
the NCI the NCI match trial that has
2014 in arms open including several
drugs that target several of the low
prevalence alterations that we've seen
in pancreatic cancer and ask those taper
trial in addition gives us access to 15
3 min times
and again several it included several
clubs that are targeted to low
prevalence alterations that we see on
through the new year tuna program in
addition there are some molecularly
targeted clinical trials that are open
for pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma one
is the pollo trial which is testing harp
inhibitor or liquid in patients that
have broccoli patients that have zero
line raka mutations and testing the
effectiveness of apartment limiter so
the mutations in genes in the BRCA
pathway are altered the ability of the
cells to repair double-stranded breaks
in the DNA that are often called caused
by chemotherapy or that are as a result
of genomic instability in cancer that
however there's an alternative if that
would clear pathway is been isn't is
ineffective there is an alternative
pathway that uses the enzyme art on a DQ
I go swimming race and so the
combination of having a defect in the
repair enzymes and the brachot pathway
and adding a small molecular inhibitor a
drug that that targets part results in
death of those cancer cells the
inability to repair that damage a cancer
death and so that's a very targeted
therapy that's being applied to
pancreatic cancer specifically and to
those individuals that have alterations
in DNA repair pathways and in addition
there we've had we've had some success
in pancreatic cancer with immunotherapy
and
you know with a subset of patients that
our microsatellite monster on state or
we have a defect so give me a pair that
lead to thousands of somatic mutations
that increase the the mutation of
various patients and that is a signal
for or the immune system and so in those
cases of pd-1 inhibitor for instance
losing that has been fda-approved now in
solid tumors which includes pain kinetic
kids are for individuals that have a
molecular indication of being
microcephaly unstable or having mismatch
repair deficiency and so this is
estimated to be about two to three
percent of pancreatic cancer patients
who have the molecular signatures for
microsatellite instance instability or
mismatch repair deficiencies and that
can be treated now on label with the FDA
approved it PB wanted editor
so again advances in in pancreatic
cancer that are more likely driven and
finally there's a clinical trial that is
using molecular information to for a
targeted therapy that targets the stroma
so this very robust normal response that
we see in pancreatic kids to one of the
components of that decimal plastic
response is harmonic acid it's part of
the matrix sort of a stroma in
pancreatic cancer and it causes it is in
part responsible for the increased
pressure within these chains so they're
there they drug pH twenty my house I'm
and a clinical trial hallo 301
uses this hyaluronidase to break down
the hyaluronic acid within pancreatic
cancer within the stroma to release the
pressure it's given in combination with
genocided equals a black site so
patients are being screened for the
presence of high levels of hyaluronic
acid and then randomized to receive this
pegylated recombinant holidays in
combination with gemcitabine and attack
salt in a clinical trial that will test
a targeted therapy a huge point for
disruption of the stroma so this is a
very exciting advance in the pancreatic
cancer field to have these molecularly
targeted trials that are specific for
one of the real challenges in pancreatic
cancer so the way that the Pancreatic
Cancer Action Network is thinking about
these advances in precision medicine
precision oncology these advances in
using molecular information from
Virginia for the treatment of pancreatic
cancer is that it's we're probably going
to need to use these molecular
approaches in combination and so the
overall goal is a molecularly driven
precision medicine the combinatorial
approach to pancreatic cancer therapy
identifying targets within a stronger
that can be targeted within the tumor
itself the tumor ultimate DNA
alterations within the tune itself that
can be targeted as well as identifying
the immune system how the immune system
can each
and putting these three approaches
together to for a really comprehensive
approach to pancreatic cancer so with
this in mind the Pancreatic Cancer
Action Network has started a new
initiative that tries to take advantage
of what we've learned in pancreatic
cancer and putting it together under one
roof the you are initiating a clinical
trial and research platform that we call
precision promise decision promise is
won by a steering committee unsupported
by the Pegman Cancer Action Network it
includes a clinical trial consortium so
twelve sites clinical trial sites
throughout the United States that will
enroll patients onto clinical trials and
it also includes a research platform so
work their translational and clinically
relevant research that can then
transition into the precision promise
platform we have the twelve sites have
been identified and we're anticipating
that the clinical trial that's being
developed within precision promise will
launch in 2018 so we are the the goal of
this is to place these clinical trials
under one umbrella so that we can more
rapidly learn from within the pancreatic
cancer space and advance the field more
rapidly so we have both no your tuner
and precision promise they both
incorporate molecular profiles molecular
driven oncology into their approach
we know your tumor we can enroll
patients from anywhere across the
country where precision promise patients
will enroll at one of the
well clinical trial consortium states
now your tumor is open for all patients
except for newly diagnosed patients
because of the time that's required to
get the molecular profile information
back on so those patients will need to
start treatment immediately
but the news their molecular profile or
their next treatment decision precision
promise will be open for metastatic
patients for newly diagnosed and
second-line treatment patients so that
we will be able to accommodate newly
diagnosed patients within the precision
promise platform patients can enroll in
clinical trials through know your tumor
any clinical trial across the United
States
precision promise will be running its
own clinical trials were busy an
adaptive trial design which includes
many ARMs that in essence rotate
precision promise so they'll both
contribute to the knowledge gained to
improve treatment options and in essence
through this approach we have treatments
that we think will advance pancreatic
cancer research for patients throughout
the United States regardless so in
addition we need to identify the best
practice and disseminate them across the
country we do this eastern part through
the patient registry so the patient
registry was set up as a way to
understand the what the journeys that
patients are taking in both high volume
centers as well as across in the United
States it is a registry where patients
determine their own privacy settings and
their access settings or or their own
information it is made up of 20-some
different
surveys that patients then take and tell
us more about their diagnosis about
their treatments and side-effects there
is an opportunity to upload molecular
profiling information map tests symptom
management family history and then their
medical history we have been this is a
and an initiative that's been in place a
little over a year now
we have over a thousand profiles and
five thousand surveys that have been
started 50 states plus the District of
Columbia and 24 countries outside of the
United States have been helping us by
giving providing us information from the
patient registry we find users have a
very strong desire to share their
information both with other researchers
and other patients most of the users are
patients and also it's there's also the
opportunity for caregivers to provide
information as well we've started to -
data looking in particular our first
project was to look at pancreatic enzyme
replacement therapy or pert and the
symptomatic response we find that 75% of
the registry participants are aware of
enzyme replacement therapy as a as a
management of symptoms of gastric
dysfunction inability to digest food and
take up nutrients for these patients you
have an often not pancreatic cancer and
he was pancreas and there exocrine
function is compromised we find that of
those individuals that are taking enzyme
replacement therapy 61 of the 61 percent
of them are taking them as its
recommended so there are individual
taking either before meals or afternoons
but not drawing meals and we find that
those that ends that end up taking their
their enzymes during their meal record a
much greater alleviation of symptoms of
feeling of indigestion and so it's this
kind this is an example of the kind of
information that we can start to learn
and perhaps a way erase the the goal is
to raise an awareness across the United
States that it may not be sufficient to
simply prescribe pancreatic enzymes to
your pancreatic cancer patients but it
may be essential to really follow up and
make sure they're using them
appropriately to alleviate the symptoms
so we are collecting data through our
patient central through our trial finder
patient registry know your tour and
precision promise these are all
different initiatives that we have that
we are both helping patients
individually as well as learning from
those patients and so we are publishing
that information making sure it gets
disseminated across the United States
and we're also undergoing initiatives to
make sure that that research those is
also available to researchers across the
United States and this one for instance
data use agreements to use the
information that the pentad Cancer
Action Network has been has been and
will acquired as they through these
initiatives that are designed to not
only help current patients but to help
future patients as well and finally we
really need to make sure that one of the
challenges with pancreatic cancer is
really a lack of awareness across the
United States in order to achieve the
goal of survival by 2020 we have an
amazing volunteer Network we are have a
presence
in communities across the United States
we have an affiliate Network and their
affiliates raise awareness or purple
stride events they raise revenue for the
organization to accomplish the
initiatives that we've outlined and to
really they are really the way that we
get the word out that they are
passionate volunteers about the activity
and making sure that more people are
aware of cancer and are helping in this
fight to to make advances against this
very deadly disease in addition there's
a global effort that we are helping to
organize the world pancreatic cancer
coalition which is a coalition in 20
countries across the world the advocacy
groups and interested individuals have
come together so look at really raising
awareness November is pancreatic cancer
awareness um there's pancreatic cancer
[Music]
awareness so we have a multi-faceted
plan of attack to help us reach our goal
of doubling survival by 2020 will we
make that call we are certainly it's all
hands on deck to try to accomplish that
goal we have seen advances in the
five-year survival rate for pancreatic
cancer which is in kind of the gold
standard metric for advances in in
survival in diseases when we started in
1999 the five-year survival rate was 4%
when we when we declared that we would
start we would double survival by 2020
and 2011 a five-year survival rate was
6% it has increased one person
each year over the past three years to
the current rate of 9% in the databases
that can be amended across years and so
we think we are making advances we have
to continue this until we hit our 2020
goal and of course use that as a
foundation for much more sustained and
substantial advances against this
disease as we go forward we are working
diligently towards that towards that end
and the bottom line is that there are
many people counting on us and others
and researchers to make those advances
to make them a little better for those
facing a man in cancer so thank you and
I am happy to take questions
thank you dr. mitrice en for that
informative presentation and your
important research we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on your screen
and click that send button well answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started we have a great
audience today here's our first question
dr. mitrice han how does know your tumor
work who pays for the diagnostic tests
what about the off-label treatments
so no your tumor works by patients that
fall patient central or we have some
very dedicated physicians across the
United States who encourage patients to
enroll in in this program the the
molecular we pay for preparers concierge
service we need pay for the ability of
their to help make sure that the biopsy
is done appropriately so that sufficient
tissue can be obtained we then pay for
the report that's generated from that
the the molecular analysis itself is
done by certified laboratories across
the United States and those laboratories
bill the patient's insurance for the
molecular diagnostic tests itself the
what we have found is that we have
insurance has been willing to pay for
those with for those alterations that
that has been a many indicated cost to
insurance for for those diagnostic tests
now patients of course we have co-pays
are responsible for those co-pays but
all the molecular analysis the analysis
of the results and the treatment
recommendations are provided by
preparing resources that need now as as
I said the options can range from
standard of care options to which are of
course provided by insurance to
off-label treatments and clinical trials
now the off-label treatments we have had
there are times because these treatments
are not approved in pancreatic cancer
there has sometimes been questions about
the use of those targeted therapies in
pancreatic cancer what we have found is
that with the appropriate scientific
information define the use of those
treatments for for treatment of
individuals with a molecular indication
in their to note that we have been
successful in getting insurance
reimbursement for those treatments that
will take some extra work and we are
happy to help patients with go through
the process of doing that or we have
again a number of the physicians that
have been actively involved in this
paper have found that it's been very
effective and to provide that
information to the insurance companies
thank you dr. Mary Ann and thank you
again to our audience numbers we have
one more question from our audience if
precision promise is a clinical trial at
12 sites
how will it accelerate progress since
accrual to clinic clinical trials will
still be limiting
so precision promise is taking the
approach that we can accelerate progress
by warm rap by putting different drugs
different tests all under one umbrella
and it uses a Bayesian adaptive trial
design something that the FDA is very
interested in these days and we have
been working very closely with the FDA
to work out the trial design so that so
that drugs can be approved through this
process using much fewer numbers of
patients than have been traditionally
needed for phase three clinical trials
so what we find is that we can share
controls so instead of each based VD
clinical trial needing both controls and
and the experimental arm that we can in
essence share across the experimental
arms by having controls plus a number of
different experimental arms all under
the precision umbrella so in addition
then this is the trial design as a phase
to three clinical trial so there can be
in essence advancement to Phase three if
the phase two results are sufficient
that in essence keeps the trial going
seamlessly so it prevents the start and
stop that occurs with traditional trial
design and it reduces the number of
patients that are needed because of this
adaptive trial design that means
designed of it is it will in essence so
it accelerates it reduces the number of
patients by sharing controls and in
essence setting up the statistics
upfront to be able to use that adaptive
trial design for registration purposes
and and it accelerates it by having
individuals instead of starting and
stopping and essence seeing as they're
going to Phase three
in addition position promise is set up
so that both patients in both first line
and second line can go into this trial
so that in essence there is the next
step in their journey is already already
at their fingertips so individuals that
go on clinical trials if they find that
they need to go on to another treatment
option instead of an essence starting
over and looking for the next clinical
trial it's all built within that same
platform so those are a couple of the
innovations that precision promise
offers to pancreatic cancer patients to
try to assembly the process
thank you dr. mitrice Han did you want
to have any closing remarks for our
audience before we close today I want to
thank the audience for their attention
for their interest in pancreatic cancer
and say that that as a as a community we
are we need to work together in order to
combat some of our biggest challenges
and that includes diseases like
pancreatic cancer thank you for your
attention
I'd like to once again think dr. matru
CN for a presentation I'd also like to
think lab roots we're making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know that the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye